the village of pookie la in southern
Finland has seen better days for years
it's been drowning in debt which keeps
getting bigger but City Council says
that's about to change every Monday it
meets to try to turn pookie laws
fortunes around the first order of
business is the lottery cup each of the
nine town council members puts a coin in
the cup and chooses a number for the
weekly super jackpot and they'll really
need a big win to balance pookie laws
budget and eliminate its four million
euros in debt more than Camilla IV news
of course we hope to win but more
importantly we want to send a message to
the government things can't go on like
this swamis moon bears the melee of our
villages suffered so many cuts and the
government saves money wherever it can
whether in social services or health
care we have nothing left to cut you
Colletti Mekhi wants to show us what
that means he takes us out for a tour
through his cash-strapped village on his
tractor we're heading for what is
generally a source of pride in Finland
the local school Finland's pupils rank
among the world's best thanks in part to
high investment in education but that's
not the case in poo Kela here fundings
been cut by thousands of euros leading
classrooms looking distinctly old school
mon van woloson is either I'm afraid
that in future our children won't have
the skills that other pupils do because
there's no longer money for computers
and software booster that on daman and
that's a crying shame says you call a
team a key because his village is
actually one of the richest in Finland
the man who was the source of those
witches lived here a century ago on
inaud me was born in pookie LA when he
died in 1962 he bequeathed his
birthplace all he had including 780
shares in a company called nokia back
then the firm produced rubber boots but
after it switched to making cell phones
nokia share price soared and Ani normies
the quest was suddenly worth 30 million
euros but there was a catch ottawa-based
of the 12 of them the money made from
the sales of the shares is designated to
making the lives of the old people that
pookie loves retirement home as
comfortable as possible when Austin
utica stuck sexy
that's why this poor village has what
must be the world's swankiest senior
citizens home it's a real Wellness
Center complete with Jim a sauna and a
swimming pool millions have been spent
for the benefit of just two dozen
seniors who did it down because I love
that that's like a five-star hotel here
yeah the accommodation is so nice and
the food is great we have everything
here those visual looked at the mounting
York City it was on the normies last
will and testament there's debris and we
must respect that step away would be
like yo Colletti mech he does respect
ani normies wishes but looking around
the homes lovely japanese garden he
can't help feeling a little envious raha
voice tonight sometimes just before I
fall asleep at night I imagine how nice
it would be to have just a little of
that money at our disposal sada it's a
led by levanta la sala possible one
thing the town councilor does have is
the support of pookie la citizens
they're protesting Helsinki's
cost-cutting measures and backing Letty
Mackey's lottery scheme when people
started talking about us playing the
lottery everyone wanted to take part not
only here in pookie LA but in the
neighboring villages to mean I'm excited
if we win there'll be enough money for
us to afford new homes county for hello
cut off then comes the most exciting
part the drawing of the lottery numbers
cookieless got a ticket with four of the
winning numbers that's worth more than a
hundred euros
hey if we win the jackpot will throw a
really big party so far they've invested
1,200 euros but only one a thousand
maybe playing the lottery isn't the best
way for poo kila to get out of debt
after all